that's life everybody should watch that
over and over again to me what do you
see young people nobody gives a [ __ ] I
I'm sorry your friends can't help you
your family actually can't help you at
the end of the day like if you want to
make something of your life you that's
that is watch that because the world
goes like this I know all your excuses
and some people have really good ones it
still doesn't matter they go get him the
[ __ ] out of here there's just too many
people there's only so much room at the
front of the plane there's only so much
room on the coast there's only so much
room that you know there's only so many
good views and you got to compete for it
otherwise what do you want what you want
to do nobody owes you well that way
nobody owes you anything yeah no bring
that kid just didn't want it bad enough
excuses that's fine we guess what the
guy really wants it badly he gets that
slop no he's on the team yeah he's on
Themis and you know what that plane I
call it fair I call it fours
well that's the NFL's only fit my dad
said that one time I said that to my dad
so what's great about sports yeah you
know what my dad said one time he said I
was business I don't know how you do it
and I go it's fair what business
shopping yeah because I wasn't getting
jobs you know yeah and I was going
through I was getting a lot of
rejections and and he said I don't know
how you do it man I don't know how you
do it
I think it's just a [ __ ] my mother's
like it's a crazy business it makes no
sense I go makes a lot of sense it's
actually very fair whatever you want to
say sometimes well whatever you want to
say the people that I know that that
become huge like like you know they're
so disciplined and they leave nothing to
chance and they're detail-oriented hmm
when I look back at all my stuff look
I'm talented I've done well but I'd
there are a lot of opportunities that
for whatever reason and as I look at it
back it was I didn't like acting as much
but you know you you make whatever you
want happen I know that sometimes things
aren't fair I know that I'm not saying
that the world does but I don't care
nobody care doesn't matter it doesn't
matter it just doesn't what are your
excuses tell me I'll give you you know
okay that's crazy that first thing you
realize the first time watching hard
night as though it is way worse I love
it it's been way worse where guys who in
this this season they and me was just
the the
the Oakland Raiders but usually they'll
show you like a young guy who's like
he's on the cusp of making it and they
show his family you get so invested in
this free agent like god I hope he makes
it they find out I guess so
oh you get so invested in guys yeah and
then gets [ __ ] cut and like what the
[ __ ] yeah and but then it didn't show it
this season but the Easter Show I'm
cutting it you just show the coach says
yeah the cameras there and he's like
it's just not gonna work man we go
through the numbers and you didn't make
like that's as real as it gets
I seen that on you know - it's the worst
and the head coach haha Oh coach the one
who does it right times did you depends
who you are depends though yeah
depends they told me that I just know
and they yo they not gonna generally get
your PlayBook well that's that that's
what happen you yeah get your playbook
but you know it's there's a weird sense
of relief to you know I don't know it's
weird
yeah it's sense really puts us like ah
[ __ ] that's a terrible that devastating
thing though to not make it black and
white bill you know red and I were
talking a long time ago for anybody is
interested in being successful and stuff
you and I were talking about no but we
were talking about how I'm like we both
for a long time just missed in a lot of
our life and just keep changing your
approach and keep going and the one
thing that we always talk about is like
what's what's going on
what negative stuff is happening what
what's what people are saying what cool
I'll just keep going you just keep going
it doesn't matter you just keep going
you know just keep getting better
this looks great about sports pretty
black you but that's what I love about
stand-up too though in a way it's pretty
black and one rather funnier yeah either
they're laughing they're not and it's
very black and it economy works you know
calm me words to this one the reason I
love comedy works you know comma works
won't let certain acts come there if
they're not legit comedians I know the
first year I was headlining they
wouldn't let me come in you know that
yeah I had to go in on I think it was a
Wednesday night and they were right
there one percent I had to come down a
Wednesday night do it one show and then
they will see what where you're at and
then we'll see if we'll let you in next
year in the year after that yes I did
that one night just flew in for that
remember just
say that your hometown club doesn't work
that way they need to see you in person
to do one night and that's to see if you
can headline in the following years so I
did that then went on some other City I
did that got past and then that's how I
got that's why I say the weekend that's
why I said a lot of young comics want to
open my feature and I know certain
people who are friends and I and I go
you you I don't want to showcase you yet
because you're actually not ready to
feature right now because what will
happen is the clubs are watching this oh
oh man if you were coming in you're not
ready why ancien but you're not ready
it's gonna sit you so far but a sold-out
crowd on a Saturday night bring the
money you can't have silence oh man you
can't be working [ __ ] out play those
those major clubs they do not play
Cobb's
I mean go whew hold list there's certain
areas where if it's not going well man
they're gonna they're gonna change your
approach correct not in a good way not
in a good way you either have the goods
you know it's okay that's what it is but
you know yeah the crowds gonna let you
know there's it's not really up for
debate
yeah like oh man I thought I did good
you know man there's no way they were
talking about that there was some debate
and among the SEAL Teams from I heard
where the training is I've to get your
tribe in this crazy because you go
through buzz but then you're invited
into a commando unit I get they call you
an F ng a [ __ ] new guy and then you
kind of have to prove yourself over the
year you know it's a long long process
but they were saying that you know a lot
of guys just get they can't deal with
the cold in the water and they've been
but most of our wars are fought in
deserts now they're not fought you know
but you know the guys were like also but
but that's also part of mental toughness
and for whatever reason your body can't
handle it you know it's not for you it's
just not for you know cuz this guy who
can't yeah my neck is too long I would I
would okay doughnuts and coffee the
first day I can't handle the cold
there's no for you but otherwise I can
handle everything else yeah yeah you'd
make it if it weren't for the collage
yeah yeah the skills yeah you know cuz I
can really do this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[ __ ] business